Judging from how complicated this looks
right now, they're probably going to be a
lot of steps involved in simplifying this
expression. So, let's just get started.
The first thing I'm going to do is use the
Distributive Property to distribute
multiplication of -3x to every term inside
the parentheses. Remember that it doesn't
matter how many terms are inside the
parentheses, we still multiply every
single on of them. So, for now, that's the
only thing that I'm going to change. I'm
going to leave everything else, all the
other terms in the expression, exactly as
they are. So now, we have this long
expanded expression. I'm really sorry. I
had to erase your challenge warning sign,
but know that I still think this is a
challenge problem. Now, we'll simplify it
within each term. You'll notice that I
haven't switched any of these operator
signs to minus signs yet so I'll do that
in this next step. So, wherever I'm adding
a negative term, I'm actually just
subtracting that term. So, instead of plus
-3xy, I'll actually just have -3xy. And
now finally, we get to rearrange our terms
so that like terms are next to each other
and simplify. And so, here's our final
answer. You still have six terms, which
just goes to show you sometimes, you can't
do anything more to make an expression
look any prettier. But it definitely is a
bit less complicated than it was at the
beginning. I know this was a really tough
problem and again, there were many, many
opportunities for little mistakes to be
made. So, if you got even part of this
right, especially practicing the
distributive property, that is awesome.
So, if you made a little mistake, go back
and try it again. The Distributive
Property will keep popping up at different
places throughout the course so it's super
important that you really, really
understand it. Although, probably not all
the problems we do will be quite as
complicated as this one.